[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
Collider coverage at San Diego comic-con
2019 we are kicking off our interview
suite with a very special group of
people I'm sitting here with some of the
cast from ABC's emergence I watched the
pilot yesterday congratulations I had a
lot of fun with it one thing that I was
left with though after is that obviously
there's a really big mystery at play
here but there's some very deep
character arcs that were starting to
experience so I'm curious what were the
first questions that you had for the
team behind the story was it more about
the big picture of the sci-fi nature of
the show or your characters literally my
first question was would I have to wear
a cop uniform every day day in and day
out yes please for me and he was like I
wanna wear no variation let's keep it
simple and I think today was you know
how much can we actually talk about
without ruining the mystery you know and
that's the tricky that's been the
trickiest thing for us we found out like
big reveals at different times I was
going in blind but we made it work yeah
we've had a lot of those conversations
where people go did you know that in
episode so-and-so you're going to be
this or this and you're like do you know
when you first commit to a show like
this do you only know what happens in
the pilot yeah I think it depends but
for me yes absolutely I read the pilot
and I was like this is amazing I want to
be a part of that I hope I don't die in
one of the rewrites but if I do I'll get
a lot of sympathy and then maybe they'll
like bring me back and that could be
even better so that's what my thought
process is just letting you in I always
joked that actors are like sort of
animals at the zoo it's they don't feed
them too much information in case they
get too attached to it yeah I mean it's
been on a need-to-know basis how you
approach Joe specifically and what we're
kind of like the pillars of the
character you wanted a hit because
walking away from the pilot I was so
struck by the combination of warmth and
also the safety I felt from her and just
yeah I mean I think what I really wanted
to do is make sure that she was sort of
like nurturing and caring and like like
you saved like warm and really
like a person that would we trusted with
this kid and that we wanted to be around
but I didn't want her to come off as
just like I'm just a mom like I just
love kids and like look at that poor kid
I just want to help that kid like I
wanted her to be driven by being good at
her job and just like a common sort of
sense of common decency and knows that
she could win kids over with Razzles and
that's a very important we were
obviously talking about the night shift
before so going from Doctor to cop is
there anything about adjusting to a
different profession that was more
challenging than that well I think all
my roles center around being not that
great at the profession and so as long
as I just keep that in mind I figure it
out as I go along but yeah I think one
not having to change wardrobe a lot
really key and my contract um ya know it
was definitely I think a different sense
of authority that you walk around with
in completely different fields you know
you have people's lives in your hands
and in different ways and so how you
carry that around in your body is a bit
different and then also just what level
that you're at I think by the end of
nightshift I was really really good at
my job and like professional people
trusted me I'd have gone a long way so
kind of running that back a bit to the
young either like wanting to be good at
what they do is an interesting
transition for me but it's a lot of fun
you know I feel like you could make a
whole career out of just taking a
character through the very beginnings of
their career all the way it's being an
absolute that is kind of plan but the
next profession you would want to hit
I think lawyers the obvious but if we
don't want to be too obvious I want to
do something in the rodeo clowning
clowning clownery is yeah I'm into it
and Oh with Ben we've only really
scratched the surface of what he's up to
is it journalism all from like a
conspiracy theory perspective is that
kind of his background you know I think
it's interesting he's obviously he's
obviously a little bit of an agitator
from what we've seen and he's someone
who likes to hide behind humor but I
think there's you know there's
definitely an agenda at play you know
there's an
nice kind of gray area right now where
we're at in the pilot certainly where we
don't know what his true intentions are
but he's you know and while there's that
there's plenty of Mantor between us I
think there is you know there's a
serious desire to get his job done I
think he uses the humor as a deflection
but ultimately and I think as the series
progresses we're going to realize that
there is a you know there's a person and
a professional agenda at play for sure
interesting did you build his background
at all like things that he had worked on
in the past to kind of land him in the
spot yeah absolutely I did a whole mock
portfolio of stories for now I wish I
and then you could do a prequel series
this all makes sense
Benny Benny the early years and maybe
I'll get Robert to play me yeah so a
Collider we actually play a would you
rather like TV movie version often and
because you brought it up on the show it
kind of gave me an excuse to play with
you guys right now so they're all
performance related questions movie TV
related questions so first up would you
rather sign a hundred posters or spend
ten minutes doing red carpet interviews
hundred posters I well I have really
terrible handwriting so that because I
just think the look on people's faces
would bring me joy just like what is
that signing every single poster
completely differently now yeah yeah I
think I'd have to go with the posters as
well it's you know I guess you could do
that in isolation alone and and so there
and it's a little zen-like when you
really sign a lot of things and Allison
does for relaxation
she's just signing posters well you have
to go and sign that gigantic poster we
have on what is the wall of Petco Park
it's up there it's a my face is very
large what is it like seeing something
like that for the first time because I
can't even begin to imagine it's bizarre
I wouldn't captured a picture of me
looking at it it's it's surreal it's
very strange very purple it's and it's
beautiful color scheme yeah yes really
Alexa is the one I wish we could see
Alexa seeing it Alexa likes to watch the
cast experiencing all this through a kid
perspective is just the most fun thing
it's really would you rather have to
fake sneeze or fake vomit in the scene
I'm gonna go with vom I think I could
fake vomit easier than fake sneeze and I
don't have it I'm not I'm not like oh
that would also make me actually vomit
so we both sensitive like that's why
that's crossed off my list forever and
ever if you pretended to vomit you'd be
like oh now it's like when you see
someone else really vomit then you get
that in your head and you you feel like
coming out I don't know I did I didn't
move her to fake vomit and I had a
mouthful of like it was something like
noodle soup or something and that's half
the work done for you do you know nummy
with the fake sneeze you have to really
really like guys we're missing the call
it's the sneeze because it's adorable
every time and you're not gonna hurt
your throat like if you're like you guys
are no no my I don't but like wait
midway through like one of your your
responses let's even get one more in all
right let's go with would you rather
have to eat a lot in a scene or run a
lot in a scene definitely would love to
eat all the time all the things I'm a
bottomless pit
well to be fair you can eat but also you
can spit you cannot swallow things
we're just but you can't really fake run
all day I made eating but you can't
you're right I and I feel like I was
made fun of for my running as a child so
it's probably a thing from that in the
back your head yeah it was awkward for a
while I made an ill-advised decision to
start eating as a character choice on
the Mentalist and I spent the first
couple seasons just eating an awful lot
until I realized that character calories
were real calories and I'm like oh
there's no way of separating these two I
appeared to be getting a lot larger by
all this eating so I think I'll go with
the fake running for sure lot of fake
running emergence everyone Tuesday
September 24th 10 9 central on ABC
check it out another thank you to this
crew here and guess what if you want
more emergence talk we've got a whole
nother interview with a group behind
this one coming your way real soon so
wait for this end card then click that
button and check it out